welcome to this video pramod tier was 77
maybe he might not play wolf you never
know but I know he does okay
maybe the tango there's a high
likelihood of a transposition to a bogey
in the end though not much that I can do
about it check yeah it's an interesting
line of the tvoego here like has not
cancelled and can use this h5 idea the
idea is that this quite often and makes
it more difficult for white to do
something on the King side this is more
of a pre-emptive measure than an attack
and then sometimes you can get an attack
but it's just about irritation normally
yeah seemed she does not know the idea
ya hear PG five is a very drastic
measure not sure one that I want to go
for but maybe I do just closing down the
kingside entirely hmm interesting just
drops back going for before maybe and
before I can also go back to a 6 mm
maybe queen a 4 then huh ok mmm that is
not ideal then ok going back here not
exactly what I wanted but yeah whoa very
aggressive probably good
you're taking that porn seemed fishy I
don't know maybe he's got this pressure
against city six pawn but it it also
shouldn't be forgotten that he has got
that Bishop on g2 and I've got an ID on
a fossil it's not so bad yo so what do I
move the night takes takes to eat maybe
not quite sure
tough to say he's got this you spray
yuge pressure there but how bad is it
maybe Luke see one night a five buck c7
just kills but well night comes to have
four as mentioned rook aah and then what
yeah anyway this I have to do no matter
what and then see what happens i don't
think i can sacrifice kanji form anytime
soon
never known so just that one hmm there's
nothing particularly threatening and
maybe rook c8 96 as it has idea for a
possible aj5 that's that's possible
you
1 93 95 anyway hmm yo that's true
check
he can take this 6n I saw that but I
felt I don't mind that so much of course
at least I'm getting rid of something
that annoyed me a lot
nope d 694 m
now it's just bad just bad yeah there is
playing as well what can you do not not
doing anything wrong maybe sides the
opening which was kind of wrong but he
played it very well afterwards I don't
think a lot of this G for business can
be any good but it's a I didn't exactly
refute it yeah c'mon black resins check
so well that's that what did I do wrong
here this should be ok somewhat I mean
not like it was maybe this this whole
business was wrong this movie I'm not be
too is good of course yeah I guess the
other one the other one ham to play
that's a simple the simple explanation
why I had a nap okay I wanted to go then
with with a night Jeff for of course and
this is difficult to achieve and he's
looking go before now I'm playing this
it playing this wrong I'm playing this
in some wrong way how do I have to play
here
Jim not sure to do
in some cases it does make sense to move
the sea pawn to play something like that
yeah just c5 to make sure he's not
playing c5 John okay you can get an idea
five as well it's not so bad but i did
still don't like it yeah maybe just not
committing so early but c5 could be a
threat I mean if I play castle door so
we can maybe play c5 immediately
I can do stuff like that I mean just
just develop I could be three yeah maybe
I should play like that just just like
super super super simple solid and let
him yeah I get that in then maneuver
over the Knight to f4 the way it went I
mean one problem of that walls that we
still add be pawns well maybe I should
have taken one of those pawns and like
here and I should have taken one of
those pawns here this is just probably
just too bad chaplet that very strong
way in 96 yeah i was thinking that maybe
even this helps me to get some activity
but Queen c7 is just ending ending the
game as I have to trade Queens or or
play something yeah stupid like this
night see form they played it very well
can you do that night a six-man I'd
maneuvers there but wrong out of the
opening around here that was wrong he
got too much too much play out of that
sometimes you play like that in similar
positions but here it is just too slow
okay thanks for watching